there is your top 10 in the 2021 nfl
draft the jaguars air quotes earned the
number one overall pick they did it the
old-fashioned way they lost 15 games in
a row they now have dibs on the man who
declared yesterday chris
that he's entering the draft
oh yeah back
trevor lawrence
joking over there yeah you know
it's okay go ahead i don't know what
happened that's not what i'm choking on
sometimes you know that happens that's
all right i'm i'm i'm getting emotional
about the prospect the jaguars actually
having a quarterback who was put on
earth to throw a football you're fine
they didn't have one
for a while when they had the third
overall pick they took blake bortles and
we know how that worked out trevor
lawrence in a much better position to
thrive in jacksonville
now the question becomes yeah who will
the coach be who will the gm be and and
is this the guy that that that new
regime wants we assume it will be
because
lawrence is so widely regarded as a top
prospect but if urban meyer gets that
job yeah i know i can't rule out a
flip-flop with the jets let the jets get
the number one pick pick up some draft
capital in return
and then take justin fields urban meyer
recruited justin fields ohio state how
could you how could you rule that out if
indeed meyer gets that job i don't i
don't think that's a crazy thought i
don't not at all and especially listen
you know if you have fields anywhere
close to trevor lawrence in your
evaluation process it doesn't even have
to be oh he's better than him but hey we
have them as you know equal grades or
maybe a notch below but we still think
our grade says that he's a year one
starter and by year three and four he
could be a pro bowl type player
then you do think about making that type
of move yeah there's no doubt if you
feel that confident that guy can run the
you know the system with you know you
want to run as a head coach and all that
then that is certainly a possibility i
don't know if that's going to happen
listen i think justin field certainly in
the conversation with trevor lawrence my
you know tv scouting would say
still i would still say trevor lawrence
is clearly the number one guy in my
opinion fields has a lot of things alike
there's no doubt about it like really
reminds me of a little bit more of a
athletic version of a dak prescott on
the field that's what i kind of look at
him like that's pretty damn good
quarterback if you ask me i like that
but i think trevor lawrence has a chance
to be you know a superstar in his own
right like a justin herbert and come in
and do what he did this year too so it's
going to be interesting conversation how
it plays out the urban meyer thing to
your point mike is very intriguing just
to see
yeah could it add that wrinkle and then
of course it's going to add more
speculation and movement there towards
the top of the draft which could be you
know fun during the off season too
one thing we know about the nfl and
specifically the scouting process in
advance of the draft it is extremely
inexact and there are evaluators who
become smitten by
great performances on big colleges
stages because they try to draw the line
between stepping up in that moment
and stepping up week in and week out
when the competition level is at its
highest at the nfl
and that's why the justin fields
performance last friday night
at a minimum gives the jaguars something
to think about and i know there are
plenty of people who will wag their
fingers and say no trevor lawrence is
clearly number one okay he still may be
number one
but justin fields whooped his butt head
to head and there will be evaluators who
look at that and say in that moment in
that spot one guy stepped up yeah and
the other guy stepped off sure and it
hurts trevor lawrence potentially and it
helps justin fields potentially not that
it it ultimately should matter but we
know from experience that it does
influence people who are looking for
folks who will perform on big stages
sure i i don't i you're right you know
there is going to be i think a certain
amount of nfl evaluators who will become
smitten with that performance and try to
justify
maybe other you know flaws you've seen
in the game and just go well yeah but
look at what i saw there and i
understand that listen part of
evaluating a football player is looking
at his actual actual absolute best and
going wait
okay that's his best can he consistently
do that and i think that question is out
there with justin fields i think he's
very capable of maybe being that guy you
know there's a there's there's a little
bit of like one mechanical flaw i don't
like about justin field's throwing that
bothers me a little but i haven't got to
deep dive and really really study these
guys yet mike you know fields has a
little bit of this he leads with his
elbow to throw and that can lead to
the ball going all over the place you're
not really using your body it becomes a
little bit too much of an arm throw
that's what he does it's a little bit
like carson wentz who also has some
accuracy issues at times because it
starts like this instead of where you
see a brady where the whole body goes
you and me have done that before when we
were at the super bowl a few years ago
rogers brady they use the torque of
their body and that's just a flaw i
don't mean to get so in the weeds here
with football talk um but it's something
to watch for as we go through this
process but either way both of these
guys are are really good football
players
something else to
watch for is whether or not trevor
lawrence will welcome going to
jacksonville and look jaguars fans and i
know it's been a rough year for you but
let's face it to the extent that
one or more than one home games every
year will be played in london you need
to have guys who are willing to sign on
for that and the draft makes them sign
on for whether they want to or not but
trevor lawrence has far more leverage
than a sixth round pick would have if
trevor lawrence looks at the land of the
land and wonders as the nfl continues to
grow its schedule how many times per
year am i going to be playing in london
when i really don't want to play in
london or my fiance isn't all that
interested in all these trips to london
now maybe they are maybe they are but
that's another dynamic to this as well
it could be an attraction
or it could be
something that that makes him recoil
along with the fact that the team has a
history of not being very good and we
need to see who the coach and the gm
will be i think trevor lawrence can't
make any final decisions about whether
or not he will try to engineer a way out
of jacksonville until he knows what he's
getting into in jackson sure and
and a lot of that will be determined in
the coming days and weeks and he has
plenty of time if he's going to try to
engineer something behind the scenes he
has until late april to pull that off
chris yeah he does that's right and then
yeah it's early stages he just wait see
who who the head coach is what direction
they're gonna go as a football team you
know but i you know i i mean again just
like we talked about a while ago
with the new york jets and when you
really want to go there and do that
you know yeah the jaguars are in a bad
state we know that but there's some
young talent there's some young talent
on the offensive side of the ball where
i do think like trevor lawrence could go
in there and and move the ball and they
can make plays right away i do i mean he
could he could take the league by storm
that way on the offensive side of the
ball like herbert did this year you know
and i i would think he would almost
relish the opportunity jacksonville
who's been mediocre at best throughout
their you know livelihood in the nfl
their existence since the 90s
he might have might appeal you know
there's two things i would think would
go in jacksonville's favor you know the
fact that of where they are he grew up
in georgia it's not far away you know he
knows that region his family is going to
be very accessible for them to go there
and do that you know and then the you
know the england thing that's a real
question his name is lawrence that's a
nice english last name and he might
relish the fact of like hey i can be a
global superstar playing on this team i
can go over there twice a year
dominate on really a world stage a
little bit there and all of a sudden i'm
the most global guy in the sport i would
find that kind of appealing if i was you
know coming out and relish that
opportunity
oh you're absolutely right we just don't
know what he feels about it yet and
that's a factor to keep an eye on and
look i like the idea of
having that opportunity to go create a
legacy with a team that has none
most of the teams out there have
something they can point to in the
rearview mirror where they've got great
players who did this they got to a super
bowl they won a super bowl jaguars have
gotten to an afc championship game and
no farther they've been around for 25
years now and they've never been to a
super bowl and lawrence could be the guy
who gets them there and that could be
the thing that attracts him right i want
to go to jacksonville job number one
though and it's been very quiet coming
out of jacksonville what are they going
to do at coach is it going to be urban
meyer is it going to be someone else
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports